sarah is with us in lexington kentucky
hi sarah welcome to the day to the
ramsay show how can we help
hi dave and anthony i have a little
question i'm dead
made me my husband are debt-free we've
been debt-free for three years
i took a traumatic fall in 2019 and
broke my humors down the flight of
stairs and
damaged my knee i've had one knee
surgery and i'm getting ready to have
another one
the my husband's gone four nights a week
and i don't sleep those four nights
because all my bedrooms are upstairs
so we're kind of like in a dilemma and
he didn't even want to be on dave ramsey
nine years ago but now he's turned into
a frugal
i think we should sell the house since
we have no bedrooms downstairs
and buy another house in the next over
subdivision
our house will price at 159 and it's
about the highest one in the
on the two streets and we could add on
to it for like 30
000 but then i don't think we could ever
get our money back out of it
the houses in the next subdivision are
running about 179
[Music]
but we'll probably only clear like 145
on our house
now i have we have 550 000 and 401k
and we have um our emergency fund and we
have 16
000 because i've been trying to save to
you know put on another house
16 000 that we could put on the house
but we'll still be a little bit short
what'd you say your household income is
our household income
during the debt free was 84 but since i
failed it's down to 65.
because in the last two since 2019 i've
only worked like four months each year
because
i failed and they tried to naturally
heal then they did surgery the next year
then now i've had the knee surgery i'm
going to have to have another one so
i'm only working part time okay
and so you're talking about a a
one-level house
i'm talking about a one-level house and
i need to stay in my
area because i'm like the provider for
my mother
who has cancer so i need to stay within
like a five mile radius
because you know i'm over there every
day so i you know i probably could find
something cheaper
farther away but then when she called me
in the other night you know it's going
to take me longer to get to her yeah
like if you move ten miles away it would
take you five minutes more
more yeah well she's kind of panicky on
that stuff
and honestly the house is well she gets
panicky i get panicky you're going back
into debt too
yeah well i think we could have it paid
off in a year well then save it up
yeah and just sleep on the couch for the
next year
because i don't sleep upstairs when he's
not there i i've literally i
what happened once i got up in the
middle of the night i made the wrong
turn i was disoriented and i went down
the flight of stairs and i know that
that's
emotional i'm not i'm not judging your
psychological
that's not always yeah i'm saying what
would i do
if i were your husband if i were you
in this situation i completely agree
with your desire to move yes and get
into a one level
i've got no issue with that if you're
within one year
of doing that with cash then do it with
cash or
move five minutes further away and do it
with cash
and deal with a ten minute drive to mama
instead of a five-minute drive
absolutely okay now the other thing is
they make those stair climber things
that you sit in
they're fifteen thousand but i don't
think they ever get our money back out
of that no
yeah sarah don't do it i mean i i think
you're trying to come up with all kind
of excuses listen to what dave said
you're able to climb the stairs yeah you
just don't want to right
well yeah i mean i'm able but you know
i've i've never had one knee surgery
you know it's like i'm not arguing with
you you know
and let me just tell you how weird i am
okay
uh if it's this important to you
i would move the living room furniture
into the garage and move the bedroom
into your living room
i'm so serious well we are from kentucky
i'm from tennessee so i think we got
this figured out we've got to figure it
out
it's just for a short time and if it's
that big a deal for you to get something
that's comfortable
i might rearrange something there yeah
on that first level seriously i'd
consider that as a temporary measure
it's not
it's not a five-year thing it's like
we're gonna go camping for four months
and five months until we get this money
saved up
but i think you can do this with cash if
you're careful or if you'll just make
slightly different decisions
sarah would you what you really want to
do is when you're facing something like
this and you've got
several very valid things
i want a one bedroom i mean i want a one
level
i and it's a reasonable request don't
you think absolutely
then but don't put so many other
constraints on it that you can't make
your
solution true yes like i have to be five
minutes from mom instead of ten minutes
from mom oh no
see now that one's silly yeah that one's
silly she could be 15 minutes away
yeah and and still and go move today
right or
sleep in the living room for a year yep
uh or move your bedroom to the living
room for a year
um or go into debt and pay it off in a
year but i
i i don't think that's the way i would
do that in this situation me i'm telling
my wife we're going to move away 15
minutes so we can give you what you want
right now i'll tell you what the other
thing you could do
uh you could sell the house today
absolutely
and rent a one bedroom yep for a year
yep yeah that's that's even a better
plan
except for the move two times part which
i'd rather have a root canal
but the moo because the move two times
things awful but uh but yeah that
that solves the problem very uh and
except for the two moves yeah but they
don't have to move in one year dave they
can stay there for you know two three
years
and pile up a bunch of cash exactly even
better one exactly that one level i keep
doing one bedroom one level one level
one level yeah
it could be a one level one bedroom you
know no i mean well for rent
for rent yeah just go that's that might
be your answer i like that answer dave
and uh you can move just about anywhere
if you're renting for a short period of
time
and she can save within five minutes
yeah yeah that
that might work that might work that's
another idea
but i think you're so close if it was
going to be five years to solve the
problem i might solve it differently
yes but because it's one year to solve
the problem i'm going to figure out a
way to push through
that right and avoid the debt your
husband doesn't want to go back into
his house and everything's paid off i
can empathize with that yeah
and um also empathize with you hurting
and you don't want to make you know you
don't want to make a wrong turn in the
middle of the night and start this pro
healing process
over again i have no issue with that at
all either